Право підняти державний прапор України має старший віцесержант Череватий.
Вийдіть зі строю.
Це - не армія. Це - школа. Точніше - Луганський обласний ліцей-інтернат
з посиленою військово-фізичною підготовкою "Кадетський корпус імені героїв Молодої гвардії".
Єдиний навчальний заклад такого типу на підконтрольному Україні Донбасі.
Після шикування у ліцеїстів - звичайні уроки.
Щоправда, військова специфіка відчувається навіть тут.
Класи у кадетському корпусі називають взводами.
Паралелі десятих та одинадцятих класів - це роти.
Вчителька: Стали всі рівненько. - Ліцеїст: Взвод, стати струнко!
Пані вчителько, одинадцята навчальна група до уроку готова. Незаконно відсутніх немає.
- Вчителька: Слава Україні! - Ліцеїсти: Героям Слава! - Вчителька: Сідайте, будь ласка.
Тема уроку - творчість Івана Франка. Учні пригадують повість "Захар Беркут".
Вчителька: Хто головні герої даного твору? Женю, будь ласка.
- Ліцеїст: Головними героями є Захар Беркут, це був старійшина тухольської громади,
його син Максим Беркут, боярин Тугар Вовк, а також його дочка Мирослава.
Максима можна назвати ідеалом честі і гідності...
Ці одинадцятикласники - з Луганщини, більшість - з російськомовних родин.
Тож над українською задля підготовки до ЗНО довелося добряче попрацювати.
Були такі випадки, коли алфавіт вчили. Від початку вчили букви і все гаразд було.
Немає нічого неможливого, якщо є бажання.
Вони знають, заради чого вони сюди приходять. Вони - майбутні військові.
Вони - майбутні захисники. І це, можливо, в дечому полегшує нам завдання.
Євген Череватий мріє стати розвідником.
Хлопець каже, що підготовка у кадетському корпусі більш ґрунтовна,
ніж у звичайній школі, де він навчався до 10-го класу.
Навчання тут, звісно, краще. У ліцеї кожен вчитель дійсно зацікавлений у тому,
щоб ми здали ЗНО і навчалися краще.
Після того, як я складу усі ЗНО, 6-го липня я поїду до Одеси в сухопутну академію,
щоб почати проходити вступні іспити.
Я обрав спеціальність "Кіберрозвідка" - я вважаю, що це зараз найпріоритетніше.
З класу - у ліс. На тренування тактики бою. Євген розповідає,
що стати військовим його надихнув приклад батька-прикордонника.
До того ж Євген, як і інші ліцеїсти з Луганщини, добре пам'ятає події 2014 року.
Коли почалася війна, мені було дев'ять років. Кожного ранку о 4-5 я чув,
як танки їхали центральною вулицею, на якій я жив, я бачив сам, як вони їдуть -
це було дуже гучно, дуже страшно, в якомусь сенсі.
Загально треба все одно бути підготовленим, бо не обов'язково ж саме у кіберрозвідці
сидіти все життя - можна перевестись в якийсь інший загін, бути просто розвідником.
У тактиці бою хлопці вправляються за допомогою зброї для лазертагу.
Влучання зараховується, коли інфрачервоний промінь з автомата гравця
потрапляє на сенсори, закріплені на супернику.
Декілька пострілів і звуковий сигнал буде, що тебе поранено або вбито.
Я дав пару пострілів у голову, але добив мій товариш Влад.
DW: Але в тебе не влучили? - Нікак нєт.
До війни кадетський корпус працював у Луганську.
Після захоплення міста керованими Росією бойовиками співробітники-офіцери
вийшли на підконтрольну уряду територію. Проте з Донбасу не відступили -
вже за рік відновили роботу у місті Кремінна на межі Донецької та Луганської областей.
Кремінна хоч і уникла окупації, але у 2014 році там проводився
сепаратистський референдум, а місто опинилося на лінії фронту.
Коли ми відкривалися у 2015 році, це була історична подія для цього регіону.
Особливо це було важливо для патріотично налаштованих верств Луганської області
та для молоді: тобто ми не здаємось, ми не відходимо нікуди, Україна тут.
У 2014 році ми сюди прибули десь у жовтні місяці, і по всій Кремінній пішли чутки,
що приїхали "правосєкі": "А що вони будуть робити? А хто його знає. Там же ж діти.
Там же є сироти. Можливо, кудись їх там туди, на Захід відправлять".
Пропаганда працювала зі страшною силою. Ми роз'яснюємо ситуацію.
Важкувато, але, я скажу, 2015-2016 роки із 2021 вже не порівняти -
змінюється на користь України.
Бригадний генерал Валерій Ємбаков - луганчанин.
Військову освіту отримав у Донецьку, брав участь у миротворчій місії у колишній Югославії,
навчався у Канаді. Ліцеєм керує з 2003 року.
Каже, що місія кадетського корпусу - не лише військовий вишкіл.
Кадетський корпус імені героїв Молодої гвардії співпрацює з Львівським ліцеєм імені Героїв Крут -
щороку ліцеїсти з Галичини відвідують друзів на Донбасі і навпаки.
Таким чином долають взаємні упередження і стереотипи.
Перший раз ми ледь набрали 20 хлопців. Я відверто кажу. Ледь набрали. Боялись.
DW: Чого боялися? - Як чого? Що їх там за російську мову розіпнуть, зі "шмайсера" постріляють.
А вже наступного разу, коли ми хлопців відправляли 30 чоловік,
у мене телефон був аж червоний, бо всі батьки бажали, щоб хлопці поїхали і подивились, як живе Львів.
Це, до речі, ще одне свідчення того, який злочин до 2014 року робила влада
отут на Луганщині. Коли вони роздмухували антиукраїнські, антизахідні, антикиївські настрої.
Молодь це відчуває дуже швидко. Декілька хвилин і все - я вже не розрізняю,
де мої хлопці, а де львівські. Бо вони одразу побраталися і ніяких питань немає.
На новому місці працівники ліцею-переселенця з нуля створили сучасний навчальний заклад -
з високими стандартами загальної, військової та спортивної підготовки
та гарними умовами для учнів. Нині тут навчаються понад двісті хлопців -
майже всі після закінчення обирають військову кар'єру.
Серед ліцеїстів - багато дітей військовослужбовців, є діти-сироти та переселенці.
Навчання регламентоване по-військовому жорстко - буквально до хвилини.
Від підйому о 6:20 до відбою о 21:50.
Вільний час, коли можна подивитися телевізор або зателефонувати батькам, - лише година.
Проте ліцеїсти не нарікають: навчання у кадетському корпусі - їхній свідомий вибір.
Я адаптовувався два тижні - воно прям сильно вдарило мені в мозок.
Спершу я навіть хотів піти звідси - я не витримував.
Але потім я взяв себе в руки - зрозумів, що це мені справді потрібно. Потрібно бути мужиком.
У тебе тут є мотивація, в першу чергу, щоб поїхати додому.
Хто краще навчається, той їде додому. Двієчники тут сидять.
Мабуть, не вистачає зовсім трішечки вільного часу. Це тому, що ми ще діти.
Я вважаю, потрібно все одно трохи більше часу - але на майбутнє це добре.
Додому можна поїхати на вихідні, якщо по оцінках проходиш за відомостями.
Останній раз я бачив батьків десь місяць тому.
Євген Череватий звільнення заслужив. Єдиний вихідний - неділю - проведе у бабусі,
яка живе у Кремінній. Додому у Старобільськ поїхати не встигне.
Адже попереду - ЗНО та випуск.
А далі - вступні іспити у військову академію. На омріяну спеціальність розвідника.